you better not be wasting my time no I
have too much to live for and more
important things to do we have to level
the playing field mr. Wilson to put it
plainly we have isn't it time we had a
league of our own so you've all seen
Justice League the post-credits you've
heard about what's gone on during the
movie they've also started to reveal
even more deleted scenes and some of
them are huge but if you are finding me
for the first time we do comic book
stuff every week be sure to subscribe to
get everything
they'll be giveaway stuff I'll explain
at the end of the video so on the off
chance that you haven't seen it I'll say
careful for spoilers because we will
need to talk about specific things but
these are things that were actually shot
during principal photography and then
cut out by Zack Snyder before he turned
in his studio director's cut so like
Zack Snyder turned in a cut of the film
before he had to leave the project when
people talk about the three-hour cut of
the film that's the cut that they're
talking about so a lot of it didn't have
finished cg but there was a bunch of
footage that they shot that they
intended to finish later but here we go
starting with the biggest stuff you've
obviously heard about green lantern
stuff in Justice League but that's the
Green Lantern that gets killed during
the big flashback scene from 5,000 years
ago he's not intended to be an easter
egg for anyone he's just a Green Lantern
from Earth's sector in the bring that
would eventually pass on to a number of
people eventually to abend sir then to
Hal Jordans Green Lantern but they
didn't shoot any of the Hal Jordan stuff
for the movie so Zack Snyder actually
did direct that Deathstroke post-credit
scene but what happened is is during
principal photography he shot a scene
with tomar ray in Kilowog going to meet
Batman and it was gonna be that final
after the credits scene it wasn't like
they were going to be giving him a Green
Lantern ring but because of all the
cosmic stuff that was happening the
mother box was awakening Steppenwolf's
arrival it just set off a lot of trigger
warnings and because there was no Hal
Jordan they were checking in where you
ask though is Hal Jordan and the other
Green Lantern's of Earth sector because
we know the Green Lantern Corps movie is
going to be a lethal weapon buddy cop
movie it's going to be Hal Jordan and
Jon Stewart that means if the movies
going to take place a couple years after
the events that are happening here then
they'll have been Green Lantern's for a
while
when it comes to Hal Jordan there are
still a lot more questions because if
Superman was an alien and he was
revealed to the earth during Man of
Steel wouldn't a Green Lantern show up
after that and try to help fight the
Kryptonians off so they're I mean
there's still a couple of plot holes but
just assume that Hal Jordan has been a
Green Lantern for a long time during the
events of Justice League
he just often a different part of the
universe but it's just really cool that
he was gonna do some Green Lantern stuff
it would have been a really big
world-building moment and even though
the post-credits scene they opted for is
relatively earth-based
it's still very much a DC movie
world-building moment it's just not
quite as cosmic as people had expected
before so you can kind of see the
original trajectory that Zack Snyder was
on like he wanted to tease Darkseid
really big cosmic stuff up front and
Justice League but I think the idea is
is that Warner's wanted to pull back on
that so what happened is is while they
were in principal photography
they literally scrapped the footage so
it didn't go to post-production so like
there's no CG version of this Kilowog
and tomare talking to Batman it's just
like the actors in their mocap suits but
of course last night you obviously saw
Joe Manganiello revealed his full-on
Deathstroke look just meaning that the
studio said yeah it's okay for you to
start posting pictures of this because
they do want to keep it secret for about
the first week or so to give people a
chance to see it but without talking
about all the injustice stuff that they
teased in this moment they're still
planning on making that Deathstroke
movie remember it's the same director
from the raid movie so they're still
working on the script they're gonna get
that locked down then they'll probably
announce a release date so it could be
any time in the next three years since
the movies come out though there have
been some more deleted scenes that have
been released
iris West was in the movie here I'll
play her scene there's no audio on it so
I'll just add a music track and it's
kind of janky cuz the special effects
haven't been finished but it's this big
save scene you get to see what she looks
like
[Music]
[Applause]
so she'll come back during the
flashpoint movie I've already done a
video about what's going on with that
what Geoff Johns has confirmed all the
Batman stuff that he's talked about so I
don't link for that at the end of this
but we don't have a release date for
that yet
probably the next coolest thing though
is is that Zack Snyder and the people
associated with the film have been
posting more pictures of the people from
this big flashback war so we finally got
to look at Zeus Artemis in Ares most of
you will know how different they look
from the Wonder Woman movie versions of
those characters so Ares for instance
played by David Thewlis great actor just
a very different idea of what the god of
war might look like although he teases
he's not the God of War I'm the God of
truth but that's not him saying that
he's a different god that really was
Ares that Wonder Woman was fighting but
the thing is is that during this period
it's before the revolt before Ares kills
all the other gods so he's at full power
this version of Ares was struck down by
Zeus and left in this weakened state but
he was left permanently weakened and
then you can assume that later he killed
artemis but if you're not sure who she
was during that big battle there's an
arrow that fires into one of Steppenwolf
ships and it explodes that's obviously
her she has the super arrows Zeus and
Ares are the one with the lightning
blast if you weren't sure about how
their powers work the children of Zeus
also have some of his powers which is
why Wonder Woman can generate those
lightning arcs they do a little better
job of showing it off during the Wonder
Woman movie
well let me know in the comments what's
your favourite deleted scene these are
obviously all in addition to the other
deleted scenes video that I posted which
I'll also add a link for at the end of
this because there's a ton of stuff I
think the biggest questions were how
much stuff was actually cut in of that
stuff how much of it was finished CG so
there's stuff during the course of
shooting that they drop like the Green
Lantern Batman scene but then there are
a lot of scenes that are completed and
just get cut down for time so most of
the deleted scenes on the DVD release
will probably be those finished CG
scenes I'm not expecting to see this
Green Lantern stuff maybe we'll see some
concept art usually that's what they do
that's like the bone that they throw
people like hey we can't release this
footage because it looks kind of janky
but here's the concept teaser this is
what it was going to look like the main
reason why they probably decided not to
do that Green Lantern scene is just
because they wanted to leave themselves
the option to change what Green
Lantern's would look like so if they get
to the Green Lantern Corps movie down
the road and they want it to look
different it's a lot easier for them to
make that change but that doesn't mean
that we won't see how Jordans some time
before then I think that when we get a
little bit closer they'll start teasing
em more but I'm not expecting another
Justice League movie for a while I think
like the next real big world building
movie we'll see will be flashpoint and
technically that's only world building
because of the timeline changes so
whatever ends up happening if they make
any big announcements about what the
schedule is going to be for all the
movies that I'll post an update but
otherwise all the movies that you've
heard about that are coming in the next
year like Aquaman and Wonder Woman -
those are still coming out when they
said that they were coming out there is
a new round of that blank giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video congratulations to the winner from
last week's video
Erin please private message me so I can
get your contact details you can click
here for more Justice League deleted
scenes and you can click here to learn
all about the flashpoint movie thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight